hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the first of July today and you're
watching games what news kids and stuff
about some things
first up GTA online is getting itself a
special July 4th update and if you love
America then you'll love this
gratuitously stereotypical America PAC
the Independence Day update which you
can grab on ps3 and xbox360 includes a
made in the USA t-shirts a mullet and
masks of what the update calls this
great nation's most fearsome and
majestic creatures there are also some
gaudy star-spangled vehicles including
the sovereign motorcycle and the
Liberator monster truck as full of guns
like the musket and firework rocket when
you're done with all your gun-toting and
red white and blue vehicle riding you
can also head down to pleasure here to
ride the ferris whale and a Leviathan
rollercoaster the content is available
for a limited time only so grab it soon
if you want to get your merica on it's
not more companies are saying yay
competition in regard to the console war
today it was Sony worldwide studios
president Shuhei Yoshida Yoshida told
nura gamer that the console war isn't
all that bad because in his words
competition really pushes everyone
Microsoft and us to do better I think in
the end the consumers will win Yoshida
went on to say that he expected
Microsoft to release a cheaper Xbox one
but not quite so quickly and he praised
the positive effects of Microsoft's
management change speaking of that
management Yoshida commented on Marcos
III showing and the new head of Xbox
Phil Spencer saying the attitude was
great like from Phil Spencer I read and
listen to his interviews and he's a
reasonably smart guy compared to some
other people who used to say some
unbelievable things some people but
densha Lee being this guy yeah
yeah and lastly Bioware is all set to
include their first ever completely gay
characters set to appear in Dragon Age
Inquisition and that's exceptionally
cool said character's name is Dorian and
he's a majors refused to align himself
with the perfect and pure attitude that
the people have where he's from lead
series writer David Gaider has said
Dorian's refusal to play along with that
facade is seen as stubborn and pointless
by his family which is contributed to
his status as a pariah the character
will not be renowned scible by women
which is why Keita confirmed that Dorian
is set to be completely gay and not gay
in the sense of many other Bioware
characters who are technically bisexual
Dorian is going to have pretty sweet
elemental spells along with those
involving the control of spirits and the
dead so even if he isn't your male
characters cup of tea he may well be
worth having in your party platonically
be sure to let me know down in that
comment box if you're keen for Dragon
Age Inquisition and what you think of
Dorian's characterization those are all
the things I have to tell you about
today but join me again same time
tomorrow for more things and until then
enjoy the rest of your day with your
things I hope you soon